[Musik]
hey ihr lieben wir machen heute unser
allererstes vapiano rezept
beziehungsweise gerade haben wir schon
und so cola sind deswegen aus dem piano
gemacht und jetzt kommt das erste
herzhafte gericht natürlich könnt ihr
mir und in die kommentare schreiben
welches sie als nächstes machen soll
aber heute machen wir pesto rosso bzw
das nudelgericht eben mit pesto rosso
und nicht zeigt euch jetzt hier erstmal
die zutaten für unser selbst gemacht das
pesto
dafür benötigen wir parmesan außerdem
getrocknete und in öl eingelegte tomaten
hier habe ich cashewkerne die habe ich
schon einmal in der pfanne angeröstet
olivenöl und frischem basilikum
chilipulver hier habe ich noch frischen
knoblauch salz und pfeffer und die
zubereitung ist super einmalig weiß
pesto rosso gibt es auch fertig zu
kaufen aber selbst macht immer besser
und dafür gebe ich jetzt erstmal alle
zutaten die wir benötigen in mein
blender und vermixt das kurz und ihr
könnt auch selbstverständlich falls
jetzt keinen solchen länder habt einfach
ein pürierstab benutzen wird
[Musik]
jetzt stehe ich gerade am herd und kocht
meine nudeln ich nehme immer am liebsten
penner ihr könnt mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr am liebsten
mit und jetzt nehme ich mir eine neue
fahne und gäbe da und sagt gerade
zubereitetes pesto hinzu für zwei
personen nämlich dann immer so ungefähr
drei große esslöffel gibt es in die
pfanne und erhitzt das dann steht ja
auch schon in der speisekarte
das im pesto cashewkerne sind und
außerdem noch pinienkernen drauf kommt
das heißt normalerweise mache ich mein
pesto immer mit pinienkernen
aber weil es dann eben auf der karte
markiert habe ich da kirsche kern rein
gegeben hatten wir aber pinienkerne
schon mal gerüstet und gäbe dass gleich
ganz am ende mit zur masse ist nämlich
das beste aber erstmal und erhitze das
mit etwas olivenöl zu setzen
[Musik]
dadurch dass wir das pesto jetzt nochmal
anbraten entfaltet sich noch mal andere
aromen und gericht schon so in den
knoblauch raus hier nochmal frischem
basilikum und ruft den einfach grob da
rein und dann braucht ihr unbedingt noch
etwas von eurem nudelwasser das nehme
ich mir immer egal welches gericht ich
koche mit nudeln ich nehme mir immer
etwas nudelwasser zu hilfe und gibt das
dann rein bis mir die konsistenz gefällt
[Musik]
die durch gegarte nudeln einfach
abtropfen lassen und je nach gewünschter
menge hin zu geben das muss jetzt auch
nur noch einmal kurz geschwenkt werden
in der pfanne und ganz zum schluss
wirklich ganz zum schluss damit eben
nicht weich und wässrig wird gehen wir
cocktailtomaten dazu die habe ich
halbiert die könnt ihr gerne auch
viertel wenn ihr möchtet und
zuallerletzt die pinienkerne
[Musik]
ich hab natürlich noch ordentlich kasan
darüber gegeben sein mal ganz ehrlich
wenn euch der oder die der koch oder die
köchin fragt möchten sie noch komme sei
sehr sagt dann ja und ruhig auch ein
bisschen mehr also ich wie parmesan auch
modeln ist einfach und jetzt probiere
ich mal für euch auch leute sein so das
ist uns probier's das ist nicht von mir
mein gott oh mein gott auch hier kommen
die schlussglocke
er schmeckt so frisch er ich sage euch
selbst gemachtes pesto ist eine andere
liga es ist eine andere liga macht
selbst es schmeckt so lecker
man sagt es eigentlich nicht ich das
auch gar nicht sagen aber ich mir
schmeckt besser als dann war pernod
bestellt ja ich war in diesem fall ist
es richtig köstlich die ganze küche
durfte okay da haben wir jetzt auch
essen ich bitte euch ganz ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen genauen mengenangaben
und den infobox hinterlassen unbedingt
nach oben und aber nicht vergessen und
dann werden uns auch beim nächsten mal
kern oder zeit vergisst nicht in die
kommentare zu schreiben was sie als
nächstes sehen möchte und dann bis zum
nächsten release und wir können und
jetzt
[Musik]